great sunday night football slate we
talked about that last hour we're going
to approach the schedule in a different
way now we're going to have a draft of
the best games of the year and again we
knew the who and the
where we just didn't know the when but
when you add the when to it it can make
games more compelling than they
otherwise would be so let's do that now
big cat gets the trivia question if he
gets it right he gets the first pick the
seahawks will travel more than 29 000
miles this season that's the most in the
nfl
which team travels the fewest miles in
the nfl this season
somewhere up close close
it's the ravens close the eagles like
don't have to get on a plane for like i
don't know there's i saw something last
night about yeah but it's the ravens
they don't leave the time zone
uh that they reside in the east coast
the eastern time zone after week two
so uh the least travel of the year the
baltimore ravens all right the first
game goes to me and my god there are so
many to choose from i gotta go chiefs
ravens week three i gotta go to the afc
championship game that wasn't what i
have to
do
i liked it it's getting quick
it's the last two mvps it's lamar
jackson patrick mahomes and this is the
next potential brady and manning they're
in two different divisions so they're
more likely to win their divisions each
year get to the playoffs be in position
where they cross paths in the playoffs
the only problem is the last two years
they haven't and it would have been
chiefs at ravens for the afc
championship game if the ravens hadn't
lost to the titans in the divisional
round and it feels inevitable that these
two guys are going to square off in
a a playoff game at some point they've
played twice in the regular season both
games were great they play again this
year and this year it's in baltimore not
in kansas city
too early in the schedule now that i'm
looking at it too early in the schedule
who cares no you lose this game it's not
earth shattering okay my first pick
later but you would have been cool but
you would have no i wouldn't have picked
it week 15
uh oh no sorry week 12
chiefs at buccaneers mahomes you said it
will be like brady and manning how about
mahomes and brady chiefs at bucks we get
to see that so that one and that
probably be the last time we see it
unless they meet in the super bowl uh
assuming that tom brady will retire
within the next four years so chiefs at
bucks you're going to get to see chiefs
and ravens all the time for the next 20
years mike florio terrible pick i'm
picking the pick that you might not ever
see again chiefs at bucks week 12 put on
the board
now i think if that game was earlier in
the year i could get on board with it
see the later the game is in the season
the less the certainty we're going to
see the great players tom brady's 43 as
of august he may he may be retired by
then both those teams will be ready to
go in the playoff hunt give me that game
number one
i'm gonna go
one of the teams yes same location
buccaneers week nine hosting the saints
on sunday night football and here's why
this will be
the first
tampa bay night game
in years that we care about the first
significant prime time game in tampa in
years really the most significant prime
time game played in tampa since super
bowl 43 when it was the cardinals and
the steelers that's how big that game is
going to be on a sunday night with drew
brees and tom brady and they already
will have played once they play week one
so this is the rematch however week one
goes this is the chance for the guy who
loses to get even in the stain needs to
get to one to one like we still are and
uh i that that get and it just it's a
big deal it's a huge game if that
stadium is ever gonna be full it's going
to be full that night unless fans aren't
allowed to be there but we continue to
be confident and optimistic that fans
will be in the stands and they will fill
that place the ray j will be rocking
don't go a knocking big cat
another terrible pick by you we've
already seen this game week one who
cares it's gonna be just a decent game
they'd probably see the same two teams
played next year two times
i'm gonna go with my next week 11
week 11
a rematch of the most stunning
playoff game from last year the
tennessee titans go to the baltimore
ravens what will we see out of this game
this is going to be a great game because
you have a team that is looking for the
ultimate revenge and a team in the
tennessee titans that we're ascending at
the end of the year had that incredible
run what will happen we will see
what what week is that game
that we that's week
who's the backup quarterback of the
tennessee titans
you can't do this you know you can't
play you know injuries
i'm not predicting injury i'm just
saying well we know bryan tannehill's
track record
whether it's injury or ineffectiveness
there's a chance whoever the backup of
the titans is going to be the
quarterback in that game if it's week
one or week two sign me up week 11 i'm
not ready to assume that we're gonna see
the best against the best that's all i'm
saying
timeout uh to quote my good friend mike
dicken i will get to the quote but you
just picked
a game in week nine with two
quarterbacks over the age of 40 and now
you're trying to tell me about injuries
mike florio who are you crapping
well but here's the thing here's the
thing that's the difference we've
already established we've we've already
i don't think it was crap and
we already established it if the terry
borge oh really yes if if if tom brady
gets injured they'll have cam newton so
that game's still compelling and if and
and if if drew brees is injured it's
jameis winston going back to tampa even
more compelling
boom roasted
eight to two
i get six points for that one no no
that's a touchdown you know it you know
it hold on case of hell's not the backup
quarterback
no he's not because thamus taysom hill
doesn't run the base offense jameis
winston does it'll be james winston
running the offense and takes him he'll
be and take some hell tend to be weird
that's weird
you're digging deeper a future franchise
quarterback according to mike flores
he's not even he's second quarterback on
the depth chart got it sean payton 21
million over two years are you saying
sean payton's an idiot
your next pick
yeah i feel like i should just conce
i've won i it's like uh
it's like it's like rest in your
starters week 17 it's over i've just
obliterated you you've been dominated
you've been destroyed you you should be
ashamed of yourself it feels good i
don't know why you do this to me every
week i kind of like this
you you aren't even close so go ahead
keep going you picked terrible i picked
a week three game in a game that has
already been done
okay uh well what do you mean again well
but still i don't care those are the
best games
one of the best game of the year last
year was the last game of the season the
49ers and the seahawks and they had
played already and they had a great game
earlier in the year but they got
together week 17 for the final game with
the one seed hanging in the balance
determines who's gonna go to the super
bowl as a practical matter comes down to
the very end and that was a game that
already had been played twelve to two
you're getting so this is your ship is
sinking man seventeen
pick a week seventeen game that no i'm
not gonna go quite that far i'm gonna go
ravens i'm gonna go raven steelers i'm
gonna go raven steelers thanksgiving
night for a couple of reasons well three
reasons first of all it's it's a a a
replay of that that notorious mike
tomlin tripping jacoby
jones on the sideline or almost tripping
him on the sideline on thanksgiving
night several years ago secondly i i
think the steelers are going to be much
better this year than last year and the
ravens are still going to be good so
it's going to be a very compelling and
competitive and meaningful game late in
the year and third it for it's just it's
the ravens and the steelers for crying
out loud we have forgotten what a great
rivalry that is i think we're going to
be reminded this year that it is a great
rivalry and i think that steelers
defense is going to be ready to go at
home with lamar jackson coming to town
thanksgiving night that's my pick book
it
okay uh my last pick will be week 13
the cincinnati bengals the miami
dolphins
two of her now you're just
okay i think it's my pen that's my pick
i'm spreading the ball around mike i'm
making sure that i have good games
everywhere most teams are are being
picked listen i'm i'm fascinated with
the same draft class you aren't you
aren't fascinated by the same draft
class i want to see who is going to uh
be the better player year one so that is
my final pick put up on the board
because i i think i did something
interesting that you aren't going to
like because i'm smarter than you
what did you do let's see let's see the
picks let's see the picks let's see i
don't know that we have the graph there
they are yeah you don't remember your
picks you've done something brilliant
but you don't remember your picks go
ahead yeah i do remember my picks mike
you have the ravens twice what happens
if lamar jackson gets hurt look at me
i've spread it around i've made sure
that i have six unique teams that's how
you do a draft
i tend to think that the best teams
create the most compelling games and
this is the best games of the year so
the best teams would be in the best
games more often than not boom roasted
14 to 2. all right we're going to take
it bruce to say who's to say also uh my
bonus pick is
uh bucks at saints week one first time
you get to see tom brady in a bucks
uniform
gonna be better than my game all right
fine my bonus pick is cowboys rams week
one first time we get to see that new
stadium with or without fans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports